donc antonio la maison et pète wii est
prête si nous dit qu il manque juste les
travailleurs antonio san antonio est
l'un des douze travailleurs mexicains de
la pépinière abbotsford arrivé en
février
tout juste avant les mesures contre la
copie de 19 qui retardent l'arrivée de
70 autres de ses collègues
les travailleurs qu'on attend c'est nos
travailleurs d'expérience
chaque année 14 mille travailleurs
agricoles du mexique et du guatemala
oeuvre dans les fermes de la province
ottawa a fermé ses frontières mais
exempte ses travailleurs reste à voir
selon quelles conditions la pépinière
voudrais assurer elles mêmes la
quarantaine obligatoires idéalement ce
serait oui qui restent à la maison qui
ne peuvent pas sortir
don du terrain la pépinière puis comme
nous l'espace et est très grand j'ai en
mesure de faire travailler de façon
séparée des autres travailleurs et la
communauté l'appui j'ai déjà même fait
des contacts avec certains des
producteurs de notre village ici à saint
paul pour la possibilité d'emprunter de
louer des maisons pour diminuer la
quantité de travailleurs par maison et
pour être en mesure de se garder des
réserves de quarantaine l'enjeu est de
taille pour les maraîchers aussi ils
vont doit décider ce que je pars mais
lorsque je lis pas bon ok quantité que
je fais quelques heures que jory le
coronavirus pourrait donner le goût aux
travailleurs de rester chez eux c'est
les choses de travailleurs des deux
n'est pas venir sauter une année donc il
va savait prendre l'année suivant
des employés qualifiés qu'on ne traite
pas facilement pour de la main d'oeuvre
locale saison commence en avril esternay
mois de novembre donc la porte à la
rooney de fiable la saison il est donc
minime - une pour les producteurs dans
la production en pépinière comme la
production de légumes
si c'est pas fait dans le bon teint ça
ne donne pas des bons résultats
deuxième génération à la pépinière
pierre paquette a vécu la crise du
verglas
cette fois ci c'est pire mais il demeure
optimiste je pense les gens vont
probablement peut-être je n'ai plus
chaud jardinage à cause de sa pipe line
jardiner plus avec la famille s'est fait
leur jardin potager puis monter aux
petits-enfants mais comment faire un
potager ici marie josée paquet comme ou
radio canada